If you're ambitious, but not sure what
to do, I'm going to share six
principles, really just actions that
have helped me get to where I want.
These are the same six things that
allowed me to go from having only a
thousand bucks to my name and sleeping
on a gym floor to now having a portfolio
of companies that last year did north of
250 million a year. And the reason I'm
making this video is because I'm on a
mission to get the next generation of
men and women to make their first
hundred thousand dollars, and there's a
lot of reasons for that, but I think
that if you can participate in the
economy, you will believe in capitalism,
and I think that will set up the next
generation for much bigger and better
things. So, let's just start with
principle number one, which is build
capacity.
And so, what to do when you're not sure
what to do is you build capacity. So,
for example, if you don't know what
you're going to do tomorrow, you should
go and bed on time today.
Uh when you're not sure what you're
going to do, still it might as well be
rested, that's building capacity. Um you
can get in shape when you don't have
dates lined up. Like, you don't have one
lined up, but it can help you when the
opportunity strikes.
Uh you can save money when you're not
sure where you're going to invest
because at least you'll have the money
so that when the investment comes,
you'll have the opportunity to take
action. It's just the thing about
opportunities is that they present
themselves to everyone, and only people
with capacity can both recognize and
capitalize on them. So, don't be in the
bleachers when the fat pitch comes. You
want to be at the plate, you want to
have already practiced your swing, and
you want to be ready to go.
And I'll give you a case study that
actually can drive this point home. So,
there was a study they did at Princeton
grad school. It was called like the good
good Samaritan study, where they had
seminary students who saw themselves as
moral people, right? They were studying
to become priests. And they asked them
to uh write a paper on being a good
Samaritan, and then to present it. All
right? And so, what was interesting
about this is that in the study, they
separated them into three groups. And
so, on the way to give the presentation,
there was this very narrow hallway into
the auditorium. And in the narrow
hallway, they put someone who had fallen
and clearly needed help. Group one was
people who were 10 minutes late. Uh
group two was people who were on time.
And group three was people who were
early. All right? Now, guess what
correlation, how people rated themselves
in their essay, had to do with the
likelihood that they would stop and help
the person.
You're right. zero. All right?
You know what did have the highest
correlation with the likelihood that
they stopped and helped the person?
How late they were. And so, and let me
tell you how big of a difference it was.
The difference between the people who
were 10 minutes early and 10 minutes
late was a 6x difference in who stopped
to actually help the person. And the
reason I see this is so important is
that right now, there are opportunities
that come to you right now that you
cannot even recognize because you do not
have capacity to do anything about it.
And so, here are some of the ways that I
recommend building capacity starting
with number two, money.
So, if you don't know what to invest in,
save money. Money buys time and time
buys optionality. And so, let's go
tactical. So, how do I go about actually
saving money? So, I'm going to walk
through each category very quickly. So,
food, that means you just don't eat out
for anything. It's very straightforward.
If you're hungry, you deal with it,
right? You only buy from discount
grocery stores. It's not that hard.
Clothing,
whatever you have right now is all you
need for the next 2 years, zero
exceptions, right? Reuse what you have,
trade, or at the very worst, you can go
to Goodwill. All right? From a housing
perspective, live as cheaply as you can,
ideally with your own family, or worst
case with another family that's also
trying to save money. Um,
and if you're like younger and you're
like, "None of us have families." and
that's fine. Then, all six of you bunk
up in one place, split bedrooms if you
have to. Um, and that's what ultimately
in the early part of my career, it was
like three or four hundred bucks a month
for me to just keep the lights on. Not
hard when you're splitting one bedroom
in a six-bedroom house. Now, all of this
stuff, we have the last cost, which is
time cost. So, think about your time
like a financial asset. Stop doom
scrolling and wasting the two to
four-hour window you have outside of
work, so your 5:00 to 9:00 a.m. and then
your 5:00 p.m. to 9:00 p.m. Those 8
hours a day, those are the hours where
you're going to have to get ahead
because you have to you have to
basically live for today to pay for
today, but you have to plan and prepare
for tomorrow, which is what those other
8 hours are for. Number three on this
stack here is add skills and practice
them. The second part is just as
important as the first. So, now you've
got some money, right? It should be
saved up. Where do you spend that money?
So, I recommend spending all excess cash
on acquiring skills until you have so
much that you can't possibly spend on
any more skills. So, increase your
capacity to earn, which increases the
value of your highest cash-producing
asset, you know that is you, right? And
what's relevant to today is that skills
are inflation-proof. Whether we're
trading in Bitcoin or seashells in the
future, if you've got value to give,
people will exchange for it. So, if
you're ever worried about all this
technology, what am I going to do? The
only thing and the only logical step you
can do is double down on skills and make
yourself more valuable. Now, understand
that learning will never hurt you. All
right, it's always additive. And even in
things that are bad, and listen, I paid
for all that stuff that I just said, and
not all of it was good. The thing is is
that I believe that winners win no
matter what. And so, how can you have
something that's bad and then you think
that you get better from it? Well, if I
learn all the things not to do, then I
learned. And if it changes my behavior
in a way that makes me more likely to
succeed, then I got better. And so, if
you if you look at the world that way,
then everything serves you rather than
you serving it. And so, I'll give you a
basic analogy from a skills perspective,
from a stacking angle. I like this
example cuz a lot of people know who he
is. So, Jay-Z's a rapper, right? And now
he's a businessman. I mean, a
businessman. Little little little If you
know, you know. Anyways,
um
in the beginning, maybe he had rhythm,
right? Maybe that's what he was
naturally born with or inclined with,
right? And then he learned how to
rap. And then he learned how to write
lyrics. And then he learned how to
market. Or rather, he probably learned
how to sell first. And then he learned
how to market. And with each of these,
he became more and more successful. And
then he learned how to get other artists
and market them. So, he learned how to
make a label. And then, he learned how
to get
Beyoncé. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> But you can see here how with each of
these skills, that person who has all of
these skills Someone who just has
rhythm, not that valuable. Someone who
can just rap, a little bit more valuable
than someone who has rhythm. Someone who
can rap and write lyrics, more valuable.
Someone who can do that and then sell,
they can sell their way into, you know,
getting shows, they can sell people on
the street. All of a sudden, they can
sell their CDs. They can sell CDs,
Jesus. They can sell
And so, he has this, which makes all of
these other things more valuable. And
then, he learned how to promote, which
made all of these other skills more
valuable. Because now, he's not just
selling out one or two, you know, small
venues, he can promote and go national.
But then, there's still a limit to the
amount that he can do here. So, that's
when he starts recruiting other people
to his labels, to his brands. And this
is what continues to stack skills. I'll
give you a financial example of this.
Maybe in the beginning, you're somebody
who's really good at math. Okay, being
good at math is not that valuable of a
skill. Then, all of a sudden, you're
like, "Okay, well, I'll learn how to do
bookkeeping." All right, well, that's
more valuable than just math, but you
need math in order to have bookkeeping.
And then, you learn how accounting
works. Okay? And then, you learn how
taxes work. And all of a sudden, you can
start saving a business money. Now, do
you need to know uh math in order to do
taxes? Yes. Do you know how to
understand how accounting works in order
to do taxes? Yes. Right? All of these
things stack. Now, let's say that you
start learning about insurance. And
then, you start learning about M&A.
Right? All of these things, you still
need to know math, but these, when taken
together, become significantly more
valuable as a person. About your second
grade math teacher as an idiot as soon
as you learn calculus, you needed
arithmetic in order to learn calculus.
And so, wherever you're at in this
journey right now, it's not like, "Oh my
god, I can't Why can't I do this?" It's
like, you still have to move through the
steps. Now, how fast do you do that
depends on how quickly you change your
behavior. And so, hopefully, this video
at least nudges you in that direction to
start changing what you do. So, the
fourth example of kind of building
capacity before you know what to do is
to build an audience without a product.
Right? So, what does that mean? So, you
don't need a product to start, you need
attention because attention gives you
leverage. And so, if you have a group of
people who know, like, and trust you,
even when you don't have a product,
you're basically building potential
energy, right? If you were the number
one most followed person on the planet,
the day you start whatever you start,
it's going to be a smashing, probably
hundred million dollars success.
Literally, if you were the most person
known person on the planet and you
charged any amount of money for
anything, you could then make basically
you'd pretty much be set for life. All
right? And so, from the building of a
quote audience, is you just talk about
the things that you're doing cuz right
now you're like, well, I don't have any
proof. Of course you don't have proof,
you haven't done anything yet. But what
you can do is do work and document the
work you do. And so, what you want to do
is like either you have epic proof or
epic effort. In the fitness world,
there's people who are like, okay, I'm
I'm six months out for my first fitness
competition. Doesn't matter where you
start, if you do something epic,
document all the volume of work you do
along the way and people will follow
you.
Now, a version of this, like the next
step here, would be build a wait list.
So, this is kind of step five. So, in
other words,
before you build the thing, build the
list of people who want the thing. So, a
person who pays with their time now is
more likely to pay with their money
later. And this is what an audience
does, you provide value them with your
time, they pay back with their time,
they say they're willing to wait for the
thing. All of these things are
indicators that they're likely or more
likely to make a purchase with you. So,
number six is
you can build capacity by building your
network potential by meeting people. So,
think about two people, one person who
stays in and watches Netflix
or somebody who goes out to a coffee
shop or someone who goes to the gym. In
either of those scenarios, your luck
surface area expands. You're more likely
for sure in each of those scenarios. And
if you do this every single day, you
continue to expand that luck exposure.
And so, if you want to be successful in
something, in anything, spend time with
the people who are already doing it
because the fastest way to change your
life is to change the people who around
you who affect your life. And so, being
willing to move to where the opportunity
is is one of the biggest kind of hacks
out there. I think Chamath talked about
this in a video, but like
if you want to be in finance, you got to
be in New York, right? If you want to be
in film, it's like you probably got to
be in Hollywood. If you want to be in
politics, you got to be in DC. Now, if
you don't want to be in those kind of
like more traditional paths, there's a
lot more places that you could be, but
the idea is like there are hubs, and if
you want to get into a space, the best
way to do it is get to the hub. And so,
if you're not sure what to do right now,
you should know exactly what to do,
which is that you build capacity and you
wait for the pitches that you can swing
at to come. And so, maybe you're getting
ball after ball after ball, but what do
you do to make sure that when the fat
pitch comes, you're ready? It's like you
practice your swing. You start doing
your sprints so that like you can
actually get around the bases faster,
right? You start working on coordination
drills. You start working on your hip
and your power. You start going to the
gym, right? All of these things will be
things that when that pitch comes,
you'll maximize the likelihood that you
smash it out of the park. But so many of
you are waiting for this fat pitch to
then begin and getting lapped by people
who already were prepared. And so, the
key word here, in order to build
capacity, you build by preparing.